- [Voiceover] So now we're
gonna use the initial conditions
to figure out our values, our
two constant values A1 and A2.
That is in our proposed
solution for current
for the LC circuit.
So one thing we need to do,
because this is a second order equation.
We need to have two initial
conditions for the variable
that we're studying here.
So we're studying I.
Right now we have one
initial condition for I,
and because we have a
second order equation.
That means we need two ic's for I.
So we have one initial
condition right here,
and what we'd like to
know is what is di dt
at time equal zero?
So the other piece of
information we have is this v.
V knot at time equal zero.
So let's use that, and we'll just
plug that straight into
the inductor equation.
so the inductor equation at t equals zero.
The voltage across the inductor is v knot,
and that equals L times di dt.
Alright and that means the
di dt equals v knot over L.
So now I have two initial conditions
in terms of I.
There's one, and there's one there.
And we can use these now
to go after A1 and A2.
First off let's plug in
I for time equals zero,
and then see if we can work
our something over here.
So that means that time equals zero.
The current is zero and that
equals A1 cosign omega knot
times, t is zero, times zero
plus A2 times sine
of omega knot times zero,
and what does this evaluate to?
Okay this is sine of zero
and sine of zero is zero,
and cosine of zero is one.
So that comes up with zero equals A1.
Okay, and A1 equals zero
means that this entire term
of our solution just dropped out.
Alright let me write what we end up with.
I equals A2 sine omega knot t.
This whole term here just
dropped out of the solution.
So here's our proposed solution down here.
Now we need to go after A2, let's do that.
As you might suspect, we're gonna use
our second initial condition to do that.
So to use our initial
condition we need di dt.
So let's take di dt of this.
So we're gonna take d dt
of this whole equation,
and on the left side we'll get di dt,
and on the other side we'll get d dt
of A2 sine omega knot t.
Okay so far so good.
Let's roll it down again.
So let's take that derivative.
We get di dt equals, A2
comes out of the derivative,
and the derivative of sine
omega knot t with respect to t
is omega knot times cosine omega knot t,
and we apply our initial condition.
Let's go to t equals zero,
and we know the di dt was v knot over L
equals A2 omega knot cosine
of omega knot times zero,
and cosine of zero goes to one,
and so we can solve for A2.
A2 equals V knot over L,
and omega knot goes down here.
So now we solve for our
second adjustable parameter
and we can write I.
I was A2 sine omega knot t.
So let's fill it in for A2.
I equals A2 is v knot over L omega knot
times sine omega knot t,
and I wanna go back now.
I wanna write this a little bit different.
I wanna go back and plug in
our value for omega knot.
So if we remember, we said
omega knot equals one over LC
and the square root of that whole thing.
So now L omega knot equals
square root of one over LC times L,
and that equals square
root of L squared over LC,
and that equals square root of L over C.
Lastly I'll write one over L omega knot
equals square root of C
over L, just the reciprocal,
and now we can write I equals
square root of C over L times V knot
sine of omega knot t,
and that is the solution
for the natural response
of an LC circuit.
It's in the form of a sine wave
and the frequency is
determined by omega knot.
Which is the two component values,
and the amplitude is
determined by the energy
we started with.
Which is represented here by V knot,
and the ratio of the two components again.
So this is why I said at the beginning
that this is where sine waves are born.